how are you guys doing today
okay
how you doing
doing excellent i really want to start
with congratulations on the movie i have
so many things i want to talk to you
guys about
specifically about your great work in
this but because we have a little extra
time i always like throwing out some fun
questions sort of like a little get to
know you i promise these are softballs
they are not hard-hitting you do not
have to be nervous um for all three of
you if you could get the financing to
make anything you want what would you
make and why
uh i would make a time machine and go
back to
2019 or 2020
when the rest of the world was being
told about the coronavirus
and uh
i don't know make it a serious thing and
not a political thing so we wouldn't be
where we are today
my i wouldn't make anything that had to
do with the film industry i'd make a
time machine and invite everybody who
would want to go back and change things
when we first heard about it
i like that answer a lot
can i can i steal octavia's answer and
ride on top of that
that's such a good one
i was i was thinking i i was going to
get what do i want to try what book do i
want to turn into a movie i could get
the budget but then she started telling
me her answer
i just want to throw my pot of money at
her time machine just to make sure it
works super effectively and we can just
do that
but after my time machine has been made
now my time this machine has been made
and you're like thinking a project
what would that project be
oh my god
um
i like throwing a big a big curve ball
right at the beginning that
that's such a massive one good yeah just
to get everything uncomfortable
put everyone on the spot in the most
intense way possible
and now we're relaxed so good to meet
you
sometimes i actually i ask this question
of other people and sometimes i get
answers that people have clearly been
thinking about you know like a project
that's been in their brain for a while
that they've never been able to
materialize dudes you you know the
subject material or budget requirements
so you know and i i believe firmly that
putting it out into the ether sometimes
can really make a difference
i think i would be drawn to do it i
don't know i don't know what the book or
the story would be but i've got
something for swords and sandals epics
they're really you know they're really
not made now um
and they're not you know they're not
associated with any there's no like ip
to grab onto
but when they're done really well
like
like gladiator it works man you watch
that movie
in the cinema you watch at home it's
just like it's a really solid movie so
to do like a cleopatra or something
or to do something on that scale that
you know that you people go to the
cinema to see i mean i can't not see
that being a great adventure picture is
michael pierce pitching an alexander the
great reboot
that would be perfect
it was eight years ago that oliver stone
one you know people need that needs a
reboot now
also that movie has like five versions
and it's confusing as to which one you
want to watch
jake can you recommend one
no
look at that
just to say i've been preparing for this
role for a while my problem i've been
very much aware of your uh
interests
oh no yeah so just yeah
happy to happy to screen test
do you want to answer do you want me to
move on to the next question
um i'm putting all my eggs into into the
into the alexander the great reboot
slash the documentary about the making
of the time machine which i think is a
is a tearjerker
i i like that answer also a lot um
what for for you guys uh what tv series
uh for risen octavia what tv series
would you love to guest star on and
michael what tv series would you love to
guest direct
uh
game of thrones
would have been uh
the one that i would just
love to
guest it on
they're filming they're filming a
prequel right now so you this again puts
it out into the ether
yeah
they bring the old one back like for
some sort of reunion i have to sneak in
i would have to be the dragon or
something you know people didn't know
that tv spencer actually played you know
the dragon
or something
it'll be like it'll be a sneaky cameo
man and i've been binging a lot of tv
recently um
i
wish i was in the wire
ah i'd love to have just been like
a substitute teacher in season four of
the wire just one of those scenes you
know that's set in the school when
they're all like
now you've got to mark the papers up
otherwise
you know
all just all just
the inside baseball of the wire just so
amazing there's so many characters
they all it's just so intricate that
every character no matter how big or how
small has a knock-on domino effect so i
would say
that either that will curb your
enthusiasm
um two good ones
now i want to hop on the wire
i would have loved to been in the wire
too
you know i i think i would have loved to
have been michael b jordan's uh
mom you know like what you know i just i
um mind hunter
yeah
i think if there's like also for
director because you're going into like
an established tv show you're going to
be
sort of um operating in the house style
to make it to some extent making it feel
consistent and cohesive and if there's
like a house style of any tv show that
you'd really gladly want to emulate
because you didn't know you'd learn
something from it it's sort of david
finch's eye
so
you know you i think as a director you
can't you'd really it'd be a really um
you'd be so glad to like um learn the
lessons of like you know working with
actors maybe you'd end up doing a lot of
takes and seeing what that experience is
like but the precision that he has with
the camera and where he cuts the sort of
the psychology that's going on in those
conversations i find that that those is
it two or three seasons maybe it's only
two but yeah it's so rewatchable
i i it really it was very painful when
uh fincher said he wasn't going to do
another season right now or possibly
ever
i don't know i don't know if you guys
have seen mind hunter but it's it's kind
of good one of my favorite shows is it's
they may not be doing another season no
i think that they released the cast from
contracts i think fincher decided that
he's not gonna do it anymore um
uh i wish i had something else to say
because the show is so good
it's one of my yeah
yeah
yeah no it's really worth your time in
terms of between the acting and the
cinematography the editing everything
about it is just you know
it's it's fincher for eight episodes you
know even though there's
anyway let's move on to your film
because i have a lot a lot of questions
um
so this is um first of all i really want
to say congratulations on the movie um
sincerely and i i thought you guys did
such a great job with it but this is one
of these tricky films to talk about
because there's a lot
you know there's a lot to it if you will
i don't want to say too much michael i
hate asking the generic question but how
have you been describing the film to
people uh without giving everything away
i try not to describe it to people uh
because we're at this early stage
festivals to some extent when i've done
intros i've just kept it really
uh short and i've talked about what
motivated me
to
to tell the story
um because it is a film that works best
like going in without knowing too much
you know i mean we released a teaser
recently like a one minute uh teaser
trailer and we're in that and then we'll
probably do something similar with the
trailer it's like trying to withhold
information
uh but the basic premise is that riz
plays malik khan who's a
combat marine and he's on a mission to
save his children from some kind of
alien threat and the film takes place
over a weekend and as much as it's a
kind of propulsive
you know well a film that's got one foot
in sci-fi one foot in thriller one in a
character study um it's also this kind
of love story between the father and his
two sons and so we really tried to
make sure the kind of the heart of the
film was like very intimate so that we
could
dance around in different genres and um
that would be like our anchor
that's about that's more than i've ever
said in any intro
i you did a great job
um and people still won't know
everything um for for you guys reason
octavia um what was it about the script
and the story that said i want to do
this
resign down before i did so i'm going to
leave him well i i
just loved the script i loved it and i
loved michael's last film beast
i was like who's this guy because it's
so hard to walk that line between as
he's saying genre and psychological
thriller whilst also really invest in
the intimacy and the texture of
relationships and really make a movie a
character portrait and he was doing that
you know
he was doing a thriller and a kind of
character study in you know and really
not um having to compromise on either it
was so kind of when we talked about
fincher i kind of see that in in in his
the precision of his eye and the kind of
clarity of of how he composes
the kind of dramatic tension
and um and so i was blown away by that
film i said what's he doing next he said
there's a script
and so i contacted michael and said hey
i know you're doing this
i'd really love to do this film with you
and um
and then yeah i was i just kind of kept
harassing him to be honest i kept
hitting him up i was like it's me up i
lobbied for it quite hard because i just
really wanted to work with him and work
on his script
and i read the script and was
blown away
um at how seamlessly um
things uh were revealed
uh and how uh beautifully
um michael um
uh
took us on this journey and we kind of
didn't
really know what we're we were
experiencing because it's all
through um
malik's uh point of view
and therefore we get a real
uh sense of of of
what he's feeling what he's going
through the fear for his children the
love
of his children
um how he feels about them and so it's
it was i just it was a page turner and
when it's a page turner you want to be a
part of it i i felt
um very fortunate to to love it
as an audience member and then um
get to to be a part of it
you uh the
because it's the opening shot in the
opening of the movie i feel like i can
talk about it there is an awesome
opening shot to this thing with the
meteor coming to the planet
and some very cool vfx and i know you
did not have all the money in the world
to make this movie so how the f did you
pull off that opening with the visual
effects and everything
we had to be uh
selective throughout the film uh because
you know the budget wasn't uh huge as
much as we tried to make it seem huge on
the screen so we had to be like very
yeah uh
specific about where we would
apply those vfx through the film and
that was like partly a budget
consideration when we were in prep and
also i suppose it was uh maybe at the
back of my head when i was writing the
script but also we just didn't want to
to be too effects driven otherwise it
would have eclipsed the kind of more
interpersonal themes and the character
work that the film was really about but
the it felt like that opening we really
needed to like get a strong foothold
into the sci-fi genre and starting out
in space i realized was such a
is such a motif within sci-fi film
whether it's 2001 or alien
or i don't know recent examples like
annihilation or
big example you know star wars starts
out in space it's like it's it really is
like a strong visual motif and then it
kind of locks
the audience's brain you're already
invited into that uh that genre space
like in um
in a very strong way and so we wanted it
was also there was also a kind of tip of
the hat to invasion of the body snatches
which has a similar
um structure where meteor was bringing
down
something i mean it's a different sort
of character in the film but it's like
infecting plants it's sort of parasite
that's used in that film and we would we
just worked really hard and for a long
time i mean maybe it was like for the
process of a year the vfx team won and
we went through many incarnations and
did a lot of uh storyboarding and
animatics to see how economic we could
be
with the vfx shots um and really just
make them sing when they were on screen
so and it was a new experience for me i
hadn't worked with vfx before
and
it actually turned out to be like a big
creative joy you know just to the
discovery of working with the whole vfx
team and what you could do
so this may be an arena that i want to
explore a bit more
so i'm glad yeah it's gratifying to hear
that it works because we there's a lot
of time and energy and conversations
that went into it
well i think the thing that people don't
realize is that everything you're seeing
is being constructed by a human it's not
like the computer is just told put a
meteor here you know you have to decide
where the camera is going to be what
it's going to look like what the fire
around the meteor is going to be
whatever and it you know it's a
essentially like creating a painting a
moving painting you know yeah when it's
out in the first couple of shots or when
it when you're out space
the best frame of reference you have is
nasa videos like there's so much great
material
that you can work from and inevitably
you find a couple of clips that you just
go well that's our that's what we're
reaching for like that level of
authenticity once you're diving inside
a sub atomic level like inside uh
capillaries and uh
inside the human brain
uh it's great because you have a bit
more creative license because who knows
what it looks like when you go
that small but at the same time you know
there's there's always a risk that it
seems
um
you know it's fantastic you know it tips
over into feeling like a pixar animation
version of it and so we were just trying
to find that very organic texture
um
that made it at least feel like a
credible
uh space
um
so yeah
um the i don't want to get this is such
a tough film to talk about with you guys
because i want to ask some specific
stuff but it'll give stuff away i'll
i'll say it like this um for you guys uh
the film deals with some very real world
themes
that um i wish i could say more about
and i'm sort of curious for um for
octavia and riz i mean i guess how did
you
prepare
for playing the characters that you
played in the film
and the way it's incorporating um
real stuff if you will it's so tricky
uh well i uh first of all i am a huge
huge ris ahmed fan
and um
to know that he was going to be
bringing
malik to light i knew he was going to be
well researched and just ready to play
i play his uh
parole officer and so michael had given
me a a few things to watch
um
so that i
understood um where he wanted hattie uh
you know how to the tone her tone her
how she approached life and so then i
did my own research
um just trying to you know
straddle that line uh uh uh the things
that we won't reveal
um as she um i had to do research there
and find out as much as i could in in
those rooms um and then uh
at the end of the day
hattie is a very empathetic woman and
she
wants um
all of her trustees to to
find a better life and do better
leave their past behind them but also
use it as a guiding force
so it was about especially the good ones
and and you know malik was always a
um
a good charge he was always a person who
did what he was supposed to do so
uh she's unnerved by
um uh some of the things that come to
light
so um i had fun you know looking into
to
some of the different subject matter
that i had to explore in order to be um
on the same page
i just said a lot of nothing
that was expert
that was some expert answering but not
answering yeah
that's well i just want to say it's it's
like every time octavia says that she's
a fan of mine i just like kind of like
you know there's a little
yelp of joy inside me you know here just
mute and just
come back
acting all cool like yeah uh man
i'm a huge fan of hers as well so
when i said to michael like who's gonna
play his role he said oh well i'll tell
this place i was like
please god please
you know i'm so so so lucky
to have her and um
yeah you know just to answer your
question about like
you know
the more you have real world research or
examples or characters or things to kind
of soak in
i think that the more helpful it can be
you know so even though this is
something takes place in the sci-fi
genre space it's also very grounded it
feels very grounded
and um
[Music]
there's a lot of kind of research we
could do like you know like like
octavia's saying speaking to people
reading but i have to say michael
himself does a lot it's kind of
he was kind of like the teacher doing
your homework for you yeah
i was like wow
because usually you get left to your own
devices to like you know dig up what you
can and soak it up but what was amazing
is michael was like okay you're doing
the role and here's your character's
backstory and here's a ton of research
and then you're like oh my god wow this
is amazing what should i what do i do
now what am i going to do this next
month how am i going to feel like i'm
you know earning a living um but of
course what's amazing about michael he
has such a specific vision so many
specific ideas but he's always really
collaborative so
at the same times he's going here's a
working template i've done all this
research
there's all these links check him out
and then tell me what you think and then
he's open to changing it and shifting it
and
so it was kind of amazing it was like uh
research can sometimes be like going
down the wormhole but with michael it
was actually very collaborative which
was new for me at least
uh i'm curious because i think one thing
about the whole sci-fi aspect
do you guys remember that last day that
we were shooting in the um
uh salt bed uh
uh
lake
and those weird lights in the sky
do you remember that like we were all
like we were like oh we were like all
the ufos are they ufos
apparently there's like a military
base nearby it was like
i think we were visited guys if we say
talk too much about this we get
assassinated so let's not talk about it
too much yeah
the men in black but i do have video
something was going on in the skies a
little bit i don't have video i i didn't
want
i don't have videos she has no footage
it's all for my memory
i um i know i'm looking at the clock and
i know i'm almost out of time with you
guys but i do have two other questions i
really want to ask uh i love talking to
actors about the way they work so i'm
curious if i'm going to give you an
example for for you guys if say you have
a very big emotional or dramatic scene
um and you know here it's filming on a
monday um i'm curious
can you talk about your process getting
ready for say the monday morning shoot
are you the day before in your head a
bunch thinking about oh [ __ ] how am i
gonna do this or like can you sort of
you know or are you days in advance
building towards it or do you go to set
monday morning and try to get there
early and mentally get in that zone to
deliver the performance that you're
required to deliver
well i i i'm gonna make mine short
because rizz had the indeed the heavy
heavy lifting here for me it's all about
the homework and you do all the homework
so that on the day
um
you're you're ready
to to
uh
be present and in the moment and when
you have amazing actors
you are glad that you did the homework
but
you really just have to exist in the
circumstances
and know that your preparation um
opposite that person it was it was easy
to be in scenes with riz and the boys um
but yeah i definitely definitely
prepare and look at the back story and
and create memories and all of those
things so that um on the day of
something very emotional i can just you
know
be there and exist in the moment
especially when you have people running
in and
fixing your makeup and all of those
things that can throw you out of of your
head space um is is better for me
um
to to make sure
that i know all the circumstances and
the things that i'm not supposed to know
as a character i don't look at that so
that they surprise me in the scene
um that's a very interesting question
what about you rizz
i've got nothing to add to that i was a
little monster class when
while she was saying that i was taking
notes off camera
you know you keep seeing my camera my
thing moving i'm making space for the
notebook i've got i mean that is that
that's that's what it is right and and
i often find that i have to kind of
continue to remind remind myself of that
and
not try and get in my own way by trying
to over control the circumstances or
control the result or
yeah it's it's like
i think that's one of the great things
about acting is it continuously teaches
you and re-teaches you the lessons we
need to learn in life which is about the
power of surrender
and and finding flow rather than
searching for control
and um
yeah ultimately you kind of you got to
kind of
know what it is and then forget about it
and trust that it's in your body
somewhere which is so hard for us
overthinking animals
but it doesn't come it doesn't
no it comes from here
and then only control that which is so
annoying
so yeah it's just it's so interesting
because i've spoken to a lot of actors
about this and you know um
some can just turn like they can be
jovial laughing and then all of a sudden
the camera's on and they are
crying and other people i've spoken to
are like no it's like a three-day
process for me i need to be thinking
about it i'm breaking down how it's
going to go and it's just so interesting
that there's no right way it's just the
way you do it
that's it yeah
michael my question for you is i'm i'm
really obsessed with the editing process
because it's the final rewrite it's
where it all comes together what did you
learn when you got in the editing room
like what were some of the big
challenges that you had to overcome and
also making sure that you were
delivering information in a way that was
not ahead of where you wanted it to be
yeah there was a lot of juggling of that
information
as the film embraces different genres
tries to continue and you know maintain
that intimacy with the
malik and his boys
i just felt like with this one even more
than beast and i mean it's kind of part
of my process anyway i really try to
um screen the film a lot to people that
aren't part of it i mean the producers
and get to see of course every cut and
they're so helpful but we also expand it
out to like friends and family
and people we don't know we do
screenings we get people to anonymize
their feedback so they really feel at
liberty to write whatever they want
it was my first experience doing test
screenings
which some directors can be a bit
cynical about but i kind of went in
wanting to get something from it and to
you know there's a lot of directors that
also find it really useful and i just
thought
you know for a film like this i think we
really need to listen to the audience
and be really really attuned to where
how information is landing
and
if it if it's landing too early or too
late or where you're losing touch with a
character
um because there was just there was just
a lot to juggle and so me and uh the
editor maya mafioli we were just like
yeah we've never i don't think
i've screened uh something so many times
to so many different people
um and the kind of virtue of doing the
test screenings was because it because
it was uh it's johan covid it meant that
it wasn't just a bunch of people in a
mall in burbank we did it all across the
states so
it was doug from texas and
leanne from the middle of nebraska it
was like
the whole spectrum of america watched
the movie and fed back on it and we
heard these focus groups that were um
they were almost like therapy sessions
for like how people were affected by the
themes in the movie it was actually like
really touching to see all these people
from different demographics share
something really personal and also
within that there was like kernels of
ideas of what we could calibrate so the
lessons that i took away was just like
you can invite the audience into the
editing process and for films like this
it doesn't kind of corrupt what you're
doing it can enhance it and it's really
helpful for me to like
continue to like calibrate my
perspective on the movie as if i'm
seeing it i get to see it through fresh
eyes through sharing it with other
people that was a lesson
do you make did you make any big changes
as a result of any of those test
screenings
it was it was
it was getting a leaner version
because it's such a propulsive story
that happens over effectively like a
weekend it's a weekend road trip it's
just like a really eventful one
and so it
felt like the best versions of it was
when it kind of embraced that pressure
cooker
uh momentum and pace
um
there was definitely versions that were
closer to um
a three-hour you know there was a
three-hour cut at the beginning
and the closer it was to the spirit of
something like good time where it was
just this you know frenetic energy and
you um
yeah that's that's where it seemed to
really work um
so it was about that it was just trying
to keep it lean and then to see and then
see what scene that we could we could do
without and still them for the film to
still hold up and then when we had all
the scenes that
we felt were really important we just
managed to give them the room to breathe
so it's not like everything felt rushed
and so it wasn't there was nothing
really dramatic a few bit you know some
switching of scene order
but nothing that was like a whole new
story beat
um
i don't think i don't think yeah that
was the case um
yeah um i'm gonna stop here because i
know that i've taken up way too much of
your time i'm just gonna say that when
we can actually talk about the movie in
a more specific way i have so many other
questions that i am holding back on
because i you know i don't want to spoil
anything for anyone um so i just want to
throw that out there but before before i
say goodbye i have to ask you riz um as
someone who's been looking forward to
exit west are you are you doing that
what's the status of that project
yeah we've been working on it for a
minute and um
yeah we're
you know developing and
that's all i can say but sure we hope to
be making it before too long
so we're trying
yeah for people that don't realize what
exit west is you guys should look it up
because it's a very very cool story and
uh you know maybe the obamas are
involved perhaps
you know and but that's a whole nother
thing
right exactly but you know i'm whatever
they want to do i'm supportive of um i
will uh i'm just going to stop here and
say that again congratulations on the
movie anything i can do to help promote
it on collider please let me know good
luck with any other interviews you're
doing today and thank you so much for
your time thank you so much thanks a lot
much love thank you thank you appreciate
it bye